à l'Assemblée nationale ce matin les
députés ont poursuivi l'examen du projet
de loi sur l'interruption de la
grossesse avant de se prononcer sur une
motion de renvoi de Monsieur Drome
député réformateur un vote pourrait
intervenir la nuit prochaine hier trois
interventions ont été particulièrement
remarqué celle de Monsieur Michel Debray
l'ancien Premier ministre celle du
docteur ponce député UDR du lotte et
celle de Jean-Pierre cotte du Parti
socialiste un mot commençant nous
pouvons faire de bonnes lois nous
pouvons constituer un bon service social
et les donn en modèle passer de la
répression aveugle à l'absence totale de
contrainte c'est aller d'un excès à
l'autre d'une erreur grave à une autre
erreur grave c'est marqué une sorte
d'abdication du législateur devant la
difficulté ce que je
propose affirmer le principe du respect
de la vie humaine ensuite accueillir
soutenir protéger promouvoir la
maternité qui sera le plus souvent une
maternité volontaire mais qui doit être
une maternité féconde enfin
déterminer les procédures raisonnables
mais
exceptionnelles selon lesquelles face à
des détresses dramatique l'interruption
de grossesse peut seulement être
autorisée VO là qui e été du bon travail
législatif car c été du bon travail
social à la fois national et
humain j'ai parlé mes chers collègues
avec mesure eu égard aux convictions de
chacun
égard à la personne du président de la
République
égard à vous-même madame le
ministre mais je ne suis pas le seul sur
les Rand cette assemblée à regretter une
grande occasion totalement
manquée madame votre courage et votre
détermination font l'admiration de vos
amis comme de vos
adversaires le qu'une femme soit venue
ici porte
l'espoir de ces centaines de milliers de
femmes qui se soumettent chaque année à
la
mutilation soit venu faire cesser ce
drame de ces centaines de frammes qui en
France meurent chaque année du fait des
avortements clandestins est en soi
quelque chose
d'important que vous madame soyez venus
ici témoigner et que vous ayez mis votre
volonté au service de cela je crois est
un gage de réussite de votre
entreprise dans cette assemblée d'hommes
et tout à l'heure en écoutant Monsieur
Michel Debray en regardant ceux qui
l'applaudissaient je cherchais les
applaudissements féminins je n'en
trouvais
pas l'ordre national n médecins n'est
pas la représentation exclusive de
somité
médical l'ordre national des médecins
est une chapelle avec un clergé mais qui
n'a plus de
fidèle je ne voudrais
pas prolonger le débat mais je crois que
ces choseslà devaient être dites je
voudrais
[Musique]
maintenant
sortir
monsieur Amel je vous écoute toujours
avec la plus grande attention et avec
beaucoup de respect et ce que je dis je
le dis sans passion mais je le dis avec
ma
conscience je voudrais maintenant mes
chers collègues que nous sortions de
cette
hémicycle le 13
décembre
1973 monsieur jeantinger garde des SA
nous disait il y a 1000 avortements
clandestins tous les jours et sur ces
1000 avortements il y a une femme qui
meurt depuis que monsieur le garde des
saau a prononcé ses paroles ici même
349 jours se sont écoulés il y a eu
349000 avortements clandestins et 349
femmes sont
mortes je
sais que le malheur arrive toujours aux
autres je sais que l'accident de la
route ça n'est jamais pour soi-même
ou pour sa propre
famille
mais songez un instant à ces 349
femmes à leur
famille imaginez quelles seraient vos
réactions s'il s'agissait de quelqu'un
qui vous touche de
près
parleriez-vous avec autant de
conviction de l'origine
exacte de la naissance de la
vie